i remember when we uh we said it was a
what's a good thing to say to someone if
you're pretending you've never seen lord
of the rings before oh yeah and someone
sits you down and says watch this movie
yeah and you say well i've never seen it
what would annoy that person yeah a few
people have sent in with something oh
great
uh dave from barnegat which is in new
jersey says always get gandalf's name
wrong
you either say it dumbledore or
ganondorf oh that's good it's good yeah
yeah because people don't like they
don't like getting their names wrong
well you shouldn't be getting gandalf
wrong because uh would you describe him
as the iconic wizard in uh fantasy
fiction
right was it was the one in arthur's
time
merlin good show maybe merlin merlin is
a good shout out thanks but i think he's
second mike from chicago said you could
every so often say wait which one is the
mother of dragons which i like which is
a game of thrones reference or you could
say is gollum one of those white walker
guys again confusing it
[Music]
with me and hold me tight all through
the night you're shining bright i'm your
voice the baby you're my pearl